Ukraine says it has no reliable
information on the passengers on board a
downed Russian plane the Kremlin says it
was carrying Ukrainian prisoners of war
the military transporter came down near
the city of belgorod in southern Russia
the defense Ministry says the aircraft
had 74 people on board including 65
ukrainians K has confirmed a prisoner
swap was due to take place on Wednesday
says the plane was carrying
weapons today ke committed a terrorist
act a Russian military transport
aircraft was downed flying from Kowski
Airfield to belgrod to transport
Ukrainian servicemen for
exchange a short time ago Russian
foreign minister Sergey lavro spoke at
the United Nations describing the
incident as a criminal act by
Kiev a Russian Transport Aircraft ill 76
was downed it was supposed to transport
from the Moscow region to belgrad 6 65
military servicemen of the Armed Forces
of Ukraine they were accompanied by
three Russian officers and a crew of six
people all of them died the Ukrainian
prisoners of War were transported to the
belgrad region in order to conduct yet
another
swap we joined Now by Daniel Hawkins
who's in Moscow and officials there
calling it a deliberate Act of terrorism
right Daniel
yeah indeed the Russian side unequivocal
from the uh early hours after this plane
crash as to who exactly was responsible
Uh Russian politicians calling this an
act of barbarity saying that after what
happened any talks and negotiations with
KF are essentially on hold uh they said
they detected two uh launches two rocket
launchers coming from the direction of
Ukraine the K region which were
responsible for the Downing of this
aircraft which they say was on its way
to conduct a prisoner exchange 192
prisoners of war from each side to be
returned home that side of the story of
course has been confirmed by the
Ukrainian authorities as well in terms
of other confirmation the Ukrainian
authorities have remained rather tight
lipped neither confirming nor denying
directly their involvement in this crash
and as you said earlier saying they
don't have any clear information as to
who or how many people were on board
this plane to start with uh the Russian
side Russian State media releasing lists
of names of people they say uh were on
this down Jet and Sergey lavro the
Russian foreign minister has called for
a security Council session at uh 300
p.m. uh New York time that's just in a
few hours time uh coming up likening
this incident to the case of bua uh when
he accused the British side of dragging
its feet and holding holding off a
session for 72 hours uh demanding that
the French uh French officials who are
of course chairing the security Council
uh agree to this demand and hold a
meeting as soon as possible to get an
explanation of why exactly this happened
so as I say from Russian officials very
unequivocal here uh who they blame uh
for this incident and uh waiting to
present their case and their version of
events of course in a few hours at the
UN security council
meeting all right thanks so much to
Daniel Hawkins from Moscow with the past
hour Ukraine's Military Intelligence has
issued a statement about the incident
let's go to Rob McBride he's joining us
from the Ukrainian Capital where is the
Ukrainian narrative on this going now
Rob yeah this is a significant statement
from the Ukrainian Military Intelligence
it is to say the least carefully worded
uh but there does seem to be a
significant change of tone this
Wednesday evening reading between the
lines it does seem uh to be given some
Credence at least to these claims by the
Russians about the uh presence of uh
Ukrainian PS prisoners of War on this
aircraft and possibly moving towards an
acceptance although the nothing official
yet but uh preparing the ground possibly
for some sort of awful acceptance on the
part of ukrainians uh that yes possibly
there were prisoners of War on board
this plane and that possibly it could
have had something to do with the down
Downing of this aircraft all officially
though that they will say for the moment
is that they have first of all confirmed
that there was due to be a prisoner
exchange this Wednesday um there then
saying that it has been called off
accusing the Russians of blaming the
Downing of this aircraft for pulling out
of this prisoner exchange saying that
they fulfilled their part of the bargain
they had turned up at the designated
rendevu point with Russian prisoners
ready to uh exchange uh and then saying
it was the Russians who did not turn up
um and then significantly accusing the
Russians of not informing the Ukrainian
side of how they were going to bring
Ukrainian prisoners to this prisoner
swap of not informing them of the route
so it does seem as though uh also in
note that saying attacking the Russians
for bringing prisoners Ukrainian
prisoners of War if indeed they were on
the plane within 30 kilometers they say
of an active war zone
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much Rob
McBride